hi and welcome to crash course cries
fear I'm silent I'm Tom and Tom's gonna
be hogging the line like this we can
doing all the science but we were
looking at melt and transport whereas
I'm gonna be doing a whole bunch of
interviews of people here from Scott
Polar Research Institute talking about
what they do for a living
[Music]
[Music]
we have covered why water at the bed of
the glacier is important but how does it
get there and how does that affect the
energy budget that was discussed in
previous episodes
just to recap the main source of energy
is of course the Sun and we refer to the
incoming and outgoing energy from the
glacier surface as the net energy
balance this dynamic surface energy
exchange means we tend to get out of
phase states at the surface of the
glacier ie we get ice turn into water
and water back to ice however if we move
deeper into the glacier about 10 to 15
meters down then the temperature of the
ice tends to remain effectively the same
this is actually quite a useful process
as it means that we can actually when we
use ice cos calculate the mean annual
air temperature for when ice was laid
down below these 10 to 15 meter layer
the majority of water in a gracious
system is actually delivered by surface
melt and rain this both delivers water
and energy to the base of the glacier as
the water freezes back on energy can
also be absorbed at the base of the
glacier via geothermal heating or
frictional heating in general water
flows following the gradient in
hydraulic potential in nature this is
always downhill I mean that's
everyone knows water flows downhill
however in the glacier this isn't
necessarily the case this is because the
hydraulic potential is modified by the
weight of the ice above it's for this
reason that under a glacier water can
actually flow uphill as it flows from an
area of high pressure to an area of low
pressure to backtrack slightly we still
have water on the surface so how does
that move around well there are three
primary ways in which water is stored
and moved on the surface of a glacier
the first of these is through fern if
you remember fern is unconsolidated snow
which has moved from beyond one season
to the next therefore it's not fully
glacier ice yet but it's a bit more
solid than the snow freshly fallen
because of this there's still lots of
gaps
air passages and pores within it water
finds it very easy to infiltrate this
and tends to flow through that fern
downhill following the little channels
that it can find it's not channelized as
such but it is moving from poor to poor
and flowing all the same the second
means by which water flows on the top of
a glacier is via channels he's got very
similar to the ones he perhaps see
elsewhere in the natural world but
interesting thing on a glacier is that
because water can switch phrase states
so quickly these channels and openings
can appear and closed very rapidly as
well on a scale of days maybe even hours
and a particularly active glaciers
surface these channels tend to be
proportional in size to the slope of
which they're sitting thirdly we have
lakes and which store water on the
glacier surface lakes can appear very
quickly on surfaces due to a high energy
flux for example if it's just very very
sunny this causes a lot of melt and
water will rapidly accumulate in any
depressions and grow from there these
lakes can then also drain incredibly
quickly as fractures open up and
channels become very rapidly formed this
means you can actually drain a huge lake
many Olympic pools in size in a matter
of hours so what I'm going to try and
demonstrate to you here is how different
pore size spacing affects percolation
now here we're using mixtures of sand
gravel and various other rocks but the
same applies to snow in terms of the
pore sizes and the spaces between the
ice crystals on my right here we have a
mixture of sand and gravel it's expected
this would normal circumstances drain
fairly well and you shouldn't have too
much water sitting on the top after a
while on my left I have a mixture of
much larger clasts and therefore you'd
expect water to drain very much more
quickly through this
however this mixture also contains a
certain amount of clay particularly clay
bound to the class because we've dried
it out but what plan is we're gonna take
each jug and pour about a liter of water
in of each and then hopefully the blue
water will help you see the percolation
happening as it moves through all the
gaps in the material and I suspect place
your bets don't gamble now on which one
will finish first so as we can see
the water on the left is ponding on the
top the air is escaping from underneath
in this one I think we may have
completely saturated the sediment there
yep pour too much water in but hopefully
you saw as it went through that it was
ponding much quicker on the top of this
one than on this one so hopefully what
you can see here and trying to use I'd
like to illuminate the side of it
is that in these larger clasts box the
water is very much all the way down to
the bottom if you're looking on the side
of the box the water has got all the way
through there's lots of gaps between and
the rocks they're there but they're
completely surrounded by water whereas
if we move to the other box what we can
see is because there's a lot of sand in
the mixture the sand is pushed down by
the water and has filled up all the pore
spaces below if you tap the box it's
still a bit of water coming but it air
bubbles coming up and those air bubbles
are trapped trapped below sand layers
which are then disturbed when we move it
so there you have the impact of sand on
the different porosity the sand is
filling in the gaps between the gravel
wears in this larger one there's no sand
or not of clay to fill the gaps between
the large clasts and therefore the water
just drops straight through it is indeed
so what we've got then is a GPS unit
that's got a little screen so you can
read off some numbers and a stick with
an antenna on the top or more precisely
it's a receiver so what happens is
you've got your GPS satellites and
they're in orbit and they are
transmitting all the time a few bits of
data so there's a time so that you know
how long your signal has taken to travel
and where it sits in relation to a few
other things so this is receiving all of
that information from multiple
satellites and using that to work out
its location so you find out the
location of this and then on the stick
we've got measurements and so what
you're doing is you're measuring how far
away the ground is from your receiver so
that you can then take that off your
final measurement when you're noting
down your result and this is a
relatively
development GPS has only been around for
the past couple of decades yeah exactly
so before that you had to be really good
at your cartography and your map making
and all those are the more traditional
forms of navigation to tell where you
were but yeah it made a lot more simple
being so yeah this is like a quantum
leap I suppose in the precision as
possible yeah and it's really important
because a lot of the polar regions don't
have huge numbers of kind of features
that you can relate to so particular
oxic is a desert so it's flat up on the
plateau
there aren't necessarily mountain ranges
that you can easily pinpoint and make
sure that you've got your location
particularly precise for so I was
chatting to someone the other day who
was going back and doing measurements in
the same places as they were taken
during the International Geophysical
Year in the late 1950s and she said the
main problem with it was actually
finding out where they had taken their
measurements because they didn't have a
means of doing really precision
locations so yeah it was a bit of hoping
they've got things in the right place so
they could do that comparison work and
also making life a lot safer because if
you know where you are people know where
you are
yeah absolutely though of course
communication is yet another challenge
because communication satellites are
different to the GPS satellites there's
quite a good constellation of GPS
satellites around but the comm
satellites aren't so good at covering
the polar regions so yeah you need to
make sure that someone knows where you
are and that you can tell them where you
are if you get in trouble yeah so that
is how the water is moving across the
surface of the glacier we'll discuss
sublation movement in much more detail
but we're missing what's in between how
does water move in glacial and glacial
just means inside the glacier English
your passages can form in three main
ways the first of these is when a
surface channel becomes in Glacial this
can happen when the Earth's surface
ablation is not greater than the creep
therefore as the channel lowers into the
ice the surface gets higher and higher
up and the creep slowly closes the top
all of a sudden your surface channel has
become an nth glacial Channel the second
mechanism is by hydraulic exploitation
of pre-existing crevasses this is where
the pressure and flow of the water in a
crevasse causes it to open up and become
more of a channel this can also lead to
the crevasses being linked up by flowing
water and finally you have the
exploitation of primeval structures by
the water so now we fold our English
channels but of course having formed
them we can also close them and the
going to happen pretty rapidly there are
three main ways in which these n glacial
channels can disappear firstly you have
an increase in the ice overburden
pressure that exceeds the ability of the
water to keep the channel open this
means that again ice creep takes over
and the channel slowly closes even if
there's water flowing in it the second
means by which a channel closes is if
the water ceases to flow at this point
you no longer have water keeping the
channel open through frictional drag or
pressure and therefore the channel
starts to close the creep naturally and
finally particularly in no marginal
areas you can have sediment back filling
the channel this happens particularly
when you have a drop in energy as the
water leaves the glacier and therefore
sediment becomes depositors this set of
a can slowly backfill eventually closing
the channel if the water pressure isn't
high enough to keep moving material away
from the entrance to the conduit all the
connection and storage mechanisms that
we've just seen can open and close very
rapidly in many ways it's this rapid
connection which is one of the key
factors of why the cryosphere responds
so quickly to climate change and changes
in their local environment these
channels can open and close and deliver
water to the bed very quickly the
deliver of this water to the bed is a
key component in glacier flow as we'll
see in the next episode now we have the
next of our interviews with Christ
barrack scientists and this week we're
talking - well let me introduce myself
I'm Gareth Reece Dante gayathri's I'm a
senior lecturer at Scott Polar Research
Institute and I'm fundamentally a
specialist in remote sensing well I will
try to define remote sensing it's it's
actually quite a tricky thing to do but
it's I mean in principle it's just
looking at something without obtaining
information from something without
coming into contact with it but for our
purposes and it's often called earth
observation when it's this kind of
remote sensing we're talking about it's
using images from satellites or aircraft
or drones or something airborne or space
form to collect collect data from the
Earth's surface you can collect data
from the atmosphere as well and
colleagues do that but that's not really
my thing so looking at the Earth's
surface from things like satellite
so every time you you know you look at
Google Earth you're actually doing some
remote sensing about 10-15 years ago I I
didn't switch exactly from looking at
the cryosphere to looking at the
vegetated environment high-latitude
vegetation but I kind of added that as a
as a major research interest and what
initially got us interested in that was
the possibility of monitoring the impact
of atmospheric pollution on high
latitude vegetation when I came to it in
the first place I thought well there
isn't any you know it's like clean place
but if you work in Russia actually
there's tons of it so we we cut our
teeth looking at the impact of
industrial pollution from things like
nickel smelting on tundra vegetation and
it's mind-boggling in its extent and its
ferocity in some places so that was
quite exciting in a negative sort of way
I guess the other thing that's really
giving me one of those Wow look at what
you can do moments is has been lighter
and that was a property crimes very
Kaplan
what happened about again about ten
years ago I would say this wasn't a new
technology it wasn't as if somebody
suddenly invented lidar this is some
using laser pulses to measure the
geometry of something you know like back
to do with their sonar but the
technology just took a step forward and
it suddenly became much much better and
we had an opportunity to collect some
data through Newark had an announcement
of opportunity from Alberta so we went
to a pet class here which is MIT
relevant bring its foul bond and I guess
the note plane flew over the last year
for 50 minutes or something like that
and it collected a data set which once
we got it back to Cambridge and
processed it just made us say wow look
what you can do nobody knew you could do
that before and you know we're all doing
it now but at the time that was very
exciting
the acquisition that gave us so the
survey they had this mission to South
Island they collected some data and they
weren't completely happy with the data
collection so they said they were gonna
run it again in two years time and
because they missed some to us
unimportant bits off the upper part of
the glassy they said well do these glass
here again for nothing so we said yeah
we're up for that and so we got two
acquisitions two years apart and again
that was at the time that was
unprecedented to have that level of
spatial and temporal resolution of
change on the glass here and yeah it had
done lots in a trunk the terminus our
trunk back by I think 13 meters in those
two years and the mean thickness had
decreased by 0.65 of a meter or
something like that so whether that's
completely attributable to climate
change or whether this is a little
bounce back from a little ice age is
probably still a bit open actually but
yes in the sense that something changed
about the climate and the glass you
respond to it it's responded to it yes
we saw that extremely clearly this
episode we covered that most water in
the Glacial system comes from surface
melt and rainfall onto the glacier
surface that lakes can form and
disappear on the surface of a glacier
very quickly and that water enters
iglasia through holes in its surface and
moves through a glacier via English your
channels all this means that water can
travel very quickly through a glacial
system providing rapid feedback between
changes in climate and precipitation
patterns and the glossiest behavior
thank you for watching crash course
cryosphere
if you'd like to take your understanding
of the subjects covered in this episode
further there are links down there in
the description and if you have
questions about the material covered and
Tom and I will be in the comments for
the next two hours after this is
uploaded we'd like to thank all of these
lovely people up here who helped make
this series possible and in particular
there are a cover project that x2
University for helping fund this and the
Scott Polar Research Institute for
housing us and being so accommodating
we'll see you next week for more I see
action